foreign
[Applause]
happy Monday everybody I hope you had a
great weekend you know I did I'd show
you pictures but you'd throw up
it's topic property for a leftist party
that despises private property the Dems
really do love taking your stuff
they let Cities Burn and businesses
close then demand reparations
you already know the California bill
that have signed into law would make it
a crime for employees to require their
workers to stop shoplifters we talked
about it it's another law that enables
criminals while handcuffing their
victims and I don't mind the handcuffing
if there's role-playing involved
but not at work if you're trying to do
your job I learned that the hard way
with Larry Kudlow
he just went home with the key
it's hard to put those pants on
so as an employee you got to take it as
people ransack your workplace when does
this stop when does this start including
car dealerships or Tiffany's why is it
just stuff that you can afford and how
far is too far I can see two cellmates
in prison one is in for rape the other
four stopping a rape
thesaurus funded DA's they're just
interchangeable
but if you work somewhere there's a
strong chance you kind of like where you
work even if you're judge jeanine's
assistant
[Laughter]
poor thing
maybe you manage the place you might
even own it and imagine someone coming
in and doing this right it's
demoralizing it's meant to be
demoralizing too demoral to remove any
possibility of passing moral judgment on
a protected class of criminals they want
us to feel like you know telling rioters
to stop writing is like telling them to
stop singing Christmas carols how
heartless are you
so we're being told it's not worth it
it's just merch but how is the store any
different from your wallet or your purse
it's all the same universe it's how it's
just how invested you are in that stuff
you're being told not to care
But ultimately excusing theft reduces
the respect everyone has for private
property it's why stealing a candy bar
when you were a kid meant going to the
police station and having your parents
pick you up it was to make sure you
never forget the feeling of Shame again
but that's been replaced with the law
telling shoplifters they can only steal
900 bucks worth of stuff a pop so we're
the ones who now feel the shame
today we're pushing the incentives in
the opposite direction that's because
the left has a problem with limits debt
limits
term limits
speed limits
having no limits means Chris Criminal
Justice Reform became a criminal
protection plan you want to stop
carjacking don't go after the carjackers
go after the cars for not preventing car
theft
they just thought writing Kia on it was
deterred enough but apparently not
well why stop there was your house too
easy to break into what if when you
defended yourself you maimed the thug if
you were told not to do that then you're
the criminal and then politicians can
remind you it's not worth it while
applauding your arrest and they will
because they know no limits well except
when it comes to people who disagree
with them then they limit your speech or
your right to run a business your way
this is crazy it appears that women only
Spas where women are naked may be forced
to accept men who say they're women but
still have their penises
yeah it's literally a move
yeah you don't want to see a pair of
testicles while having a hot stone
massage too bad that's on you the law
say you don't own your business we do so
there's a new bill that would punish
parents for misgendering their own
children
translation being accurate children
aren't property but they are your
children that's why you say these are my
kids well unless your baby mama is a
stripper and your dad is Joe Biden then
it's I've never met those women and the
children aren't mine
but when activists are told there are no
limits to their demands they can come
for your kids too it's the same logic
your family like your business is my
business it's about separating you from
what is yours property family Your Own
Story even your right to self-defense
they'll take your guns but they won't
keep you safe
I'm not a conspiracy theorist but I
don't have to be conspiracies are done
in the dark this isn't like a parade
full of fat guys and thongs twerking in
front of kids they really aren't trying
to hide it anymore
but how funny I never see this happen on
Martha's Vineyard
[Applause]
we're nice yes
that clicking sound is his typewriter or
he's cutting his toenails in public
again novelist and literary critic
Walter Kerr
her smile is bright as she fights
anti-semites human rights lawyer Brooke
Goldstein
he loves performing in prisons because
the crowd can't leave comedian Joe
DeVito
and finally she's like linoleum top
flexible and often found on bathroom
floors foxes contribute her captive
it is hot in here Walter it's been a
while I haven't seen it but you look
great I've been homeless in Las Vegas
for a while that's why I'm So Tan you
have a golden George Hamilton uh Vibe
going right now they put baby powder on
me it's actually worse than this yeah
really
so what do you make of this uh
my premise am I um am I am I weaving too
many topics together or do you feel that
there's something here about
relinquishing control
it's all about relinquishing privacy
um but let's let's take things in order
first of all the shoplifting law I think
like most insane California laws this
one doesn't go far enough they keep it
just short of ridiculous so that people
can kind of accept it so I think instead
of being prevented from stopping
shoplifters people who work in stores
should be required by law to help
shoplifters yes
um
so for example if you see a shoplifter
having trouble with a 98 inch color TV
you bring a trolley over it you know
you say listen I get off in half an hour
I've got a pickup truck if you need that
to get it home
but it's a good point because the fact
is you're actually facilitating the
theft so there's a reduction in time
spent in the store so you're actually
being helpful and if the idea is to
prevent violence yeah
um you know
being actually helpful will probably
keep things peaceful yeah but um you
know I feel sorry I still feel sorry for
clerks who can't afford the things the
shoplifters are stealing you know like
hey man you know I've been saving up
that's why I have this job and you're
just taking it out the door
um the other thing about shoplifting is
they used to have to hide and wear
raincoats and so on and now you can just
pull up your cart beside them and say
you know hey man I'm getting the Bounty
paper towels that are on sale and that
guy says no I'm getting the full price
ones I'm just stealing them yes and it
really does hurt the uh the raincoat
industry because now shoplifters aren't
buying them in bulk or they're just
stealing them and the raincoat industry
isn't necessary for flashing anymore
because as is true of your second story
you can now walk into a women's only
spot now I'm from the Midwest I'm not
comfortable seeing penises even if is a
man yes
so I can only imagine how the women feel
yes
okay
elegant extremities by any means no
nothing there nothing there seems to go
together it's a kind of a comical
collection of like you see odd features
see see Greg when I was a kid
what
I mean I've never even seen my mother
naked yeah thank God and she's passed
away now you know
I consider that lucky so I never will
but uh but what I was going to say is
when I was a kid in the midwest if you
wanted to see a naked woman's body you
had to buy a product that was advertised
in the back of magazines yes x-ray specs
yes and
if you wore x-ray specs you had a prayer
of seeing the faint outline of a woman's
naked body yes now there's no Market you
just walk into the spa yeah it's again
killed in other industry I got to move
on but um dying to hear more I have to
ask you Brooke uh you know Walter's
touching on the uh touching on the
massage place yeah isn't it interesting
how misogynistic women can be towards
other women I mean they're they're
talking about a dude who's basically
indulging his own perversion he wants to
go in there with his aroused memory
memorabilia
I'm not a doctor
anyway you know where I'm going is it
does it strike you as anti-woman very
much I think that this Court ruling is a
huge problem
um I think it's an example of legal
Warfare where the courts are being used
to violate the basic civil rights of
women to privacy and to safety and we've
seen this for example in the sports
industry where all of the gains that we
have made with the women's rights
movements have been just in a second
roll back where women who are trying
very hard to advance our being
marginalized because they're being
forced to compete with men and I want to
be very clear there is no civil right
for a man no matter how he identifies to
expose himself to women in a private
place absolutely not but women do have
civil rights to safety and protection
and I think that this judge who ruled
that anti-discrimination law should be
interpreted to violate women's rights
should be sent right back to law school
this is a huge threat and the biggest
problem is enforcement and what you
learn in law school is there is a law
that cannot be properly enforced it is a
bad law how do you know which men are
really self-identified or whatever this
can be taken advantage of but I do
disagree with you just to go back on on
the other California law and I've never
disagreed with you I think this is a
historic first I have absolutely no
problem with the bill because it doesn't
prohibit employees from stopping theft
what it does is it prohibits the
employer from inquiring and there's no
the employer should not yeah you know
Force the employee to be involved in a
dangerous situation that security
Personnel but it doesn't deal with the
problem and the problem is the insanity
that's happening in California which has
led companies like Nordstroms and Whole
Foods to close hundreds of jobs are
being lost and this has to be taken care
of all right
um Joe you've been uh I think I know
where you're going to go we don't want
to talk about the massage place these
are Korean run I believe yeah you
imagine these poor Korean women that are
like what is where this is America what
is going on yeah or maybe it was Canada
no it's Seattle yeah close close enough
yeah yeah well I agree with Brooke I
think it's very unfair that these men
can just Waltz into a woman's spot where
meanwhile I have to maintain a 50-foot
distance for a court order I think
that's very unfair
um I I think the shoplifting first thing
you need to do is you need to price
everything at 9.99 and above because
then they can't just come in and take it
right and I think the solution we need
is if you remember during the LA riots
the famous uh career they call them the
rooftop Koreans right who of course now
they would call them white supremacists
but yeah yes rooftop Koreans defended
their businesses they got there they
they use their second amendment to get
their AR-15s and go on their roofs and
people didn't come into their places
they they knew oh you don't mess around
it's the you know fool around and find
out yeah we need to bring that back if
anything what we need is to have laws
where you can hire people specifically
to beat the crap out of the shoplifters
in your store and I think that would cut
down on the shoplifting quite a bit but
now you look at the Lululemon thing if
you're the employee
just tell your friends yeah come steal
where I'm at work yeah and then we'll
split it that's exactly what I would do
yeah if I was young I would I would do
my Lulu looting on the side I would just
tell you just come in come in you know I
don't even have to be there set the
table up right out in front of the store
don't you say anything exactly and you
could take so much Lululemon stuff cat
because it's so skin it's so fine and
thin
that's true it'd be really easy to steal
leggings yeah it is it's like if you try
just a little just put them underneath
what you're already wearing and walk out
yeah exactly I used to do that I used to
uh go into the dressing room and leave
with clothes on
yeah
okay uh yeah no I agree with I agree
with you it's like you you can't have
your your employer forcing you to stop
in a potentially dangerous situation and
lose your job for it but obviously you
do have to do something but I think it's
perfectly in line with you know the
collect the view of collective property
and as opposed to private property
rights where we're individuals we own
our own stuff so it's not surprising but
they do need to do something about it I
think and I'd rather not talk about the
penises again
[Laughter]
I feel like the amount of time I have to
talk about the show was just too much
cat that's called Equity yeah
well you're gonna hate uh all penis
Wednesday
oh my God and Thursday and Friday yes
oh then we have then we have boner I
thought working at Cave I thought
working at cable news there'd be a lot
less genitalia talk involved I was gonna
be like shark week except instead of
sharks it's boners I understand that
how dangerous they are you know the
boners get a bad rap summertime they
come out people are taking pictures
anyway
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else